do you remember baby boy with tyrese
snoop dogg jose okay yeah remember when
the hair stylist is buying something
from uh i was like i'm i'm from jody i'm
gonna fit myself into this
upstager you're upstaging us
when he was selling the dresses out the
back of the tree yes yes yes yes
anyway good to see you man how's
everything what's going on man
friday hey good to see you
hey we uh we were getting into it
earlier uh off the top um talking about
these reports of uh kawhi leonard
getting star treatment above it yeah
okay look you know the story take it
away what's your thoughts on that a good
time we'll get them together
if anyone can it's ty lue
um i remember after that 2016 title
there was this you can find it somewhere
like somebody use your google analytics
skills and it's like david mcmenamin
when he was following the cavs and some
more beat writers if the guy who was
covered with um you know out in akron at
the beacon and someone else
and they did this like round table radio
show podcast and it was like two hours
and they were just chronicling all the
stuff that happened with that 2016 team
and you know stuff that was reported and
you know all the good stuff that
reporters know but just don't write
about
and what i got from that was just that
that entire season was a soap opera
david griffin talked about it throughout
that year and what it taught me is that
ty lue was very good
in messy situations and the clippers are
a very messy situation so i think they
got the right guy they didn't bring
someone from outside in he knows the
personalities
he has the respect of the locker room
because he can basically say like i have
a ring none of you do besides kawhi
um and we've seen all the issues that
happened with the clippers so i think
this was the perfect hire in the great
hire and if you know if he would have
went to houston or philly and someone
else
and bomber didn't get this done with
tyloo then the clippers would have just
been the old clippers because i just
thought this was the only person on the
market
that fit perfectly for what they need to
do now do i think this means they're
going to win a championship
no i don't see that happening but this
is the best person to clean up that mess
all right but but but let's just let's
just talk about this for a second
my man plays for the los angeles
clippers
and lives in
san diego
all right so i think that's a problem
how do you feel about that and he was
missing uh he's missing some flights
late for flights
their special treatment and then they're
just kind of taking it too far you think
that's taking it too far
look you can live wherever you want to
we're we're in a moment right now where
people are working from home and you
know doing their jobs exceptionally but
you got to show up on time if it's a
zoom meeting if it's a team playing like
you got to be there especially when your
face is on the billboards like i get you
get some start treatment and i heard
y'all earlier talking about you know kg
well kawhi ain't kg kg could do that
because kg was the vocal leader he was
the one that bought energy we knew he
was gonna hold you accountable and he's
gonna hold himself accountable kawhi
doesn't talk we don't know who he talks
to what he necessarily sounds like you
know his laugh is terrible and weird and
he's been wearing these
ugly braids for the last 15 20 years
like we don't know much about to do so
if you're just the weird dude that can
hoop and you just don't show up when you
want to like this is not really going to
go well when you got a roster full of
dudes like montrez hero lou williams
who's on the back of his other plane
eating his wings and patrick beverly uh
like this is just not a good mixture if
the guy
is not gonna talk and he's gonna be late
like there's just a lot of issues there
hold on man how are you going to talk
about my man's brains like that though
look yeah that takes father away
if i don't say nothing else i'm gonna
comment on his brain
it is not even that he has braids it's
the same straight backs since san diego
state like you can't switch them up
there's no type of designs
like do something like they're terrible
like there's no growth he ain't got no
lymph like what we doing fam let me know
like
i just i just need some type of variety
somewhere
but look all jokes aside though and i
know you're serious but
in terms of kawhi
um
because of his rings the two rings two
different teams two-time finals mvp
did we in the media maybe not you karen
but you know did we
give him a bit of a pass for this
collapse because a lot of the obviously
you know doc rivers was the fall guy
paul george took a lot of the brunt or
just the clippers going clip but
we unintentionally give uh give kawhi a
bit of a pass for what just happened
i mean it's part of the bigger problem
that we have like in the media well if
we're going to use that term
we give everybody a pass besides lebron
james like he's the only one we hold up
to this stature that
no one else can can pass or surmount
like kawhi has been getting a pass steph
curry always gets a pass like let's
really be honest that dude is not really
good in the finals except for like the
last two years he'll have moments but he
don't really show up when you need him
he did against toronto good for him but
you know kd got it over the head for
going to golden state
but if we really say steph don't show up
when you need him but i hear you though
he has not been the best player in the
finals but i mean he's you know
come on now let's not go too far with
the steps
i'm not slandering like i love steph but
when you're the
unanimous first unanimous mvp in league
history and you have no finals in vp and
you lost that that second that second
year and you blew a 3-1 lead because you
were throwing behind the back passes to
the second row like come on like
can you imagine if lebron did that
no
your overall point is airtight lebron is
held to a different standard so so by
default kawhi you're saying kawaii we
give you the same pass everybody not
named lebron goods we do it to kawhi we
do it to giannis
in a way that is
concerning
because
what giannis did in the bubble
all these reports that the miami heat
might potentially go in and get yon is
like i don't understand why
because why not we know because we
understand what the heat culture is
jimmy butler spo pat riley look at jake
crowder like look at that team that's a
bunch of tough gritty guys
giannis is the same dude that just won
defensive player of the year a couple of
weeks ago and after they lost i think in
game two or game three they asked him
did you ask coach budd if you can guard
jimmy in the fourth quarter and his
response was why would i do that
yeah how can that dude whose defensive
player of the year work in miami
in that culture i just don't see it
you figure it out i think you figure
listen if they got opportunity to get
giannis karen you got to get yachts
attention
even if you do have reservations and you
let you let jimmy butler whatever dog he
got you let jimmy brother bring it out
of here don't you
oh listen
i got concerns about it but when i
pulled the trigger yes but during
training camp oh we gonna have a couple
come to jesus moments
and we gonna get all that kool-aid
that's pumping in his heart out because
in order for this to work as good as
janice is
yeah you gotta find some dog in you
because them type of ants are just not
gonna fly because that means your
mentality is just not at the same
mentality of the rest of this team and
this franchise and this culture and
something's gonna have to change that
this is going to be able to work and we
gonna give up all these pieces to bring
you down here
all right karen the last time you were
on you mentioned that you know the dms
are open you move to a new city
hey ladies now hey hey
let's talk to me you're in chicago right
you're in chicago
yes so you got to be careful with this
answer because you know those those
prospects might say wait a minute i
don't like your answer on this
we talked a lot about lebron
versus mj
just historically
all right who do you who you got in this
debate
or is it even a debate
well i will give you an answer but first
i'll give you my disclaimer
i hate this debate i don't think this
should be a debate i think it is a
complete waste of time because it
diminishes one person
um it covers up the flaws of one person
we have revisionist history
about
you know one or the other
especially when you expand it and throw
kobe in it i just think at a place now
that like we should be able to respect
each person in the era that they've
played in if you have your favorite fine
but when we get into this debate in
barber shops on tv shows on podcasts it
gets into a lot of mud slinging and i
think it's just a really really bad take
to where
especially when it comes to lebron we're
not giving him his flowers now
and especially what happened to kobe
like i don't want us not to give someone
their flowers if they may you know
tragically leave us too early um but to
answer your question
i'm picking lebron james i think he is
the greatest basketball player that's
ever walked this earth i think lebron
james has been the best basketball
player on earth since game five of the
2007 eastern conference finals
um when he did what he did to the
pistons
um that's just my opinion when i look at
a complete basketball player in his
entitled career from high school to the
league and how long he's been doing it
like we've never seen someone's prime
this long
and look i get the different metrics and
the six for six for jordan but when you
do that you also forget about all the
first round losses
and look we're talking about a dude who
might be number one possibly in every
statistical category in the history of
the league when he's done playing
because the dude's getting ready to turn
through at 35-36 and he's still the best
player in the league like who knows how
long this would go on like he could be
at 40 playing he could still be like a
12-8 guy still putting up numbers still
making the right play so
i'm going with lebron
yo last thing i got for you man before
we let you go um
or not you never know where this
conversation might go
so love to follow you on twitter i never
asked you this
are you are you a braves fan
i have been a brave fan no since i was
like four or five
it is the first team
i was like introduced to as a kid okay
took me to old footing county stadium
and like before back home growing up in
michigan before i picked the fab five
before we just room for the bad boys
like the first memory i have of going to
an actual game of any athletic contest
was old floyd county stadium and getting
up a hat so like yeah i just been so
hurt since the 96th world series
that like i'm not a brave fan
i'm not a brave fan but i did grow up a
braves fan growing up in new orleans we
did not have a baseball team so we had
tbs atlanta right down the road so i
grew up so we probably was watching at
the same time reason i brought that up
put michael holly back on the screen i
brought that up just uh you know yeah
lava grenades
you can you can like the braves and all
that
how many division titles they went in a
row about 20 uh you know i always win a
division title about 400 always
they're about to mess this thing up for
me man they're about to mess up the
world series for me nobody trying to see
the braves in rays in the world series i
love baseball i will boycott that world
series i promise you right now i don't
want to see the braves
and rays in the world here guess what
nobody else does except for you and
michael smith
i want the dodgers and astros i want
drama i want hatred i want great players
i want the best players in baseball
going at it
braves and rays
waking me up wake me up when it's over i
mean it's cool i get it i i feel you but
if the braves pull this thing off and
ronald cunha and his dreads and the
reyes and all them cats
get a world series
like yeah
this thing gonna get real funky out in
cobb county and i need this to go down
this is payback we're blowing it at 96.
yeah we need this i'm all full
well listen i love to see this what kind
of asterisk
it's asterisk territory michael smith
if the dodgers
if the dodgers don't win it everybody
else is a pro
don't get mad
don't get mad at us because clayton
kershaw choked in the playoffs every
year like that ain't our fault we teed
off on him last night look
just listen
just give the braves this like listen
we're still hurt like i said from 96.
look man look i think
this would actually help baseball if the
braves won because let's be honest
baseball hasn't had a cool
baseball team with black players since
the braves in 95
and the stretch of players that the
braves had when you had dion and david
justice and fred mcgriff and all those
cats then you had schmultz and glavin
and all of them so look if you all want
baseball to be cool and baseball wants
ratings and baseballs wants black people
like they claim they do but we know they
really don't like this is one of the
teams that's going to have to be sexy
and be the face of the league and have
to win a world series
um that's how i was in the 90s and
that's when i was a fan because you had
all the black cool baseball players like
look i love david justice david justin's
poor holly berry like i
ken griffey jr was playing barry bonds
playing i knew they were all better but
i wanted to be that guy number 23 in red
white and blue because what he was doing
off the field because i was like oh you
can be cool and do that cool so if you
want to bring that back and you got cats
and gold chains
playing for the braves right now yeah
let this
happen for the culture hey man uh i just
i look i want him to win just to see
what you show up in
to see what kind of attire you just show
up in the world
polka dot i know that
all right we're looking forward to it i
love it man karen phillips keep up the
great work brother we appreciate you
appreciate it appreciate it
all right man all right